[Music]
Thank You Melanie for pointing that out
the truth is I get nervous and I get
cold actually and that's why this work
all right so I would like to talk about
selection bias and I title the
presentation the elephant in the room
and there's a rising selection bias is a
very important topic in the content of
machine learning especially in the
community of the practitioners of
machine learning and I personally don't
think it's getting the attention you
should so I thought it would be good to
present about it to bring up the issue
to you know show what what are the
effects of selection bias and maybe come
up with some ideas about how to how to
deal with it now selection bias is a
pretty complex topic at least for me and
it's very difficult to talk about it is
really difficult to to say things
especially without using any mathematics
so I tried to keep the math as low as
possible and what I would like to do so
to introduce a business case that I had
to solve some time ago that you know
what I had to face the issue of
selection bias maybe this helps to make
the the concepts a little bit more
concrete than just formulas and stuff
like that so let's introduce first the
business case is a problem hard to solve
for booking there we go the business
case is about guessing whether a search
is about a family trip or not now you
may wonder why would we want to do this
right why do we want to guess with a
family this is actually searching for a
family trip or not if you typically you
can actually enter data like number of
adults number of children the ages and
stuff like that right so you should know
but the problem is that about 30 percent
of the searches that come from users we
know are doing a family trip I don't
have any information about children ages
or even number of rooms or anything like
that and the main reason for that will
be to notice that they simply forget
about the kids they go to the website
they are very excited to go to Mykonos
Island or where we're going
and they go all the way to
to the booking stage they booked only to
find out they forgot Kevin so at the
point usually what happens a lot
actually is that they have to maybe
cancel the reservation because the hotel
maybe doesn't allow kids or maybe the
that particular that I chose doesn't
have enough availability to host all the
whole family so I have to consider the
situation start all over all over again
and that's quite quite a bit of hassle
especially for a family so we want to
prevent this and they will to prevent is
that a search time right at the
beginning of the final we want to tell
is this trip about a family trip or not
so we can remind them hey it looks like
you're traveling with the family give us
all the information about your kids and
stuff so we can give you more relevant
our accommodation stuff like that and of
course we can even start up from to give
more relevant recommendations because we
know what we think this is a family trip
now and of course we want to do this
only for families not for couples or
solo travelers a group travelers right
so the problem is that we want to make
this this prediction at search time but
we have information the location of the
use of destination the anticipation
which is how much in advance the user is
searching with respect to the check-in
date how long are they going to stay in
the accommodation they want to stay how
what kind of filters they are using we
have quite a bit of information and we
call this of course X this is our
feature vector this is when we want to
actually predict but the label the
target variable they want to predict we
only observe it way below in the funnel
for users at search booked stay some
users might cancel and never stay in the
hotel although they did booked it and
even the ones that stay not everybody
actually gives us a review when they
gives us this review we ask him is was
this a family trip yes or not and that's
where we get the label from but again we
want to apply this model at search stage
right and in the final people drop out
not randomly people drop out because of
reasons systematically and that
introduces bias that means that if we
want to apply machine learning with
examples of observations sample
from the search stage we're going to
observe Labor's only for a subsample
abaya subsample of those searches the
ones that actually led to a review where
we do get a label so this is an example
of selection bias and it's a typical
example that we see a lot in for example
in booking.com and it's not so typical
example of an on iid setup because if I
train my model with samples from the
rape stage only what I don't only have
labels then the distribution from what I
get the labels is very different from
distribution what I actually going to
apply the machine learning algorithm
which is again in the search stage now
the first thing I would like to do I
hope that's clear what selection bias
what what do I mean by selection bias in
the constant machine learning but the
first thing I want to do is to try to
illustrate the effect of selection bias
why is it wrong why can't we just go and
train our model on the searches that led
to a rav4 which we do have a label so we
can approaches supervisor that said
what's wrong with that what's the effect
now the catch is that I can't really
show the effect because we don't know
the labels just kind of the crux of the
problem if I knew the labels for all the
searches then I wouldn't be talking
about this right so I cheated a little
bit and although I want to show
real-life example I took examples from
the rebbe stage and I apply a bias
myself a buyer I control myself so I
call this a synthetic bias so that that
allows us or allows me to understand
exactly what's happening when we train
with label data that comes from a
different distribution from than the
population that I actually care about so
let me describe this a little bit in
more detail so what I did again a sample
from the REM stage this is our searches
for which we do have a label so the blue
are the features and the green are the
labels so we do have all the labels in
this set because that's how it's read up
now I introduce a bias and by
introducing a bias what I mean is I go
just row by row and I apply some
criteria like anticipation assistant
today's stay length is more than three
and I don't know language is not English
whatever criteria and I chess subsample
the rows that meet that criteria
I just flip a coin would say 90% and if
I get heads I've removed the label I
lose the label for that particular row
if otherwise I keep the label so that
gives me a new set which I can split
into two they said that I don't have any
labels because I dropped them using my
biasing criteria and that is the
unlabeled set and I take this set and I
just do nothing I just drop it there's
nothing I can do in the context of
supervised learning but of course I get
labels I have some label data and I can
just take this label data and apply
machine learning algorithm and get a
model out of it now this little arrow
learning is all things machine learning
hyper parameter selection feature
selection cross validation
something-something learning deep very
much all the machine learning you can
all the things if you throw them in
there and the output is a machine
learning model that were very happy with
that generalizes very well that does not
over fit and I want to put this in
production to make money next what I'm
going to do is take this model and sort
of simulate the process of putting this
model in production for that I take
another production set which is excited
is another sample from the rebbe stage
so it's exactly some distributions the
learning set and I applies exactly the
same bias but this time rather than
dropping the labels I mark the rows with
orange and that means you shouldn't or I
shouldn't have seen this label I can see
it but you shouldn't have and then I
take again the label set and I can apply
an evaluation criteria like for example
area under the ROC curve this is a
classification problem with 30% prior
something like that so it's okay to use
something like AUC and that give me one
number for one model which is the
absorber from us how will my model does
in this sample but then I also have the
labels that I said you shouldn't have
seen them the orange ones and that means
I can actually evaluate the performance
in the whole data set and that gives me
the actual performance on the production
set now the performance is a performance
that I can actually always see it's the
as you measure we measure when our
models in production we get some levels
and we measured and we know they you see
precision recall whatever you like but
the actual performance is a number is a
quantity that we cannot have access to
and that's again the whole point of
selection bias we don't have access to
the actual performance but in this case
because I'm controlling the bias myself
because I'm yeah introducing a purpose I
can actually know the actual performance
and the idea now is to observe or to try
to study a little bit the relationships
between these two variables so these two
measurements or numbers observe and the
actual performance and in order to do
that what I did is I took many different
arrows many different learning pipelines
I use simple ones like logistic
regression more complicated man ones
like factorization machines shallow
neural networks all kind of I would
assembly I think it took twelve or
something
and for each of these items I can
evaluate it and get both observed and
actual performance and that gives twelve
points in the coordinate plane so I can
plot them in a scatter plot and that's
what we see here so on the x-axis we can
see the star performance which is the
area under the ROC curve you see a
metric and on the y-axis we can see the
actual performance and this is one of
the algorithms I think this one is the
duration and we get absurd performance
what we get is about zero eight five
I guess three or something and we get
lesson zero 84 as actual performance so
that's not that bad we are losing some
AUC and to be honest if I gain one point
of a you see I go to the closest part
and celebrate so if I lose one point of
a you see I get really sad
so exactly I go to the next one yeah so
the outcome is always the same so the
point is that okay it's arguably whether
the drop in performance is relevant or
not and of course it depends a lot on
the task and the business value of one
point of AUC and I wondered but what is
a little more worrying is that if I keep
improving my model that means observe
performance keeps on increasing the
actual performance stays the same so
this is pretty bad news actually
and actually compute the regression line
it's a flat line correlation is equals
to zero so there's no correlation
between to observe an actual performance
that means you train your model you do
all this something something sneaked
very much learning and you have survey
big gain in performance or not so big
and that probably doesn't mean anything
for the actual performance why because
the bias that we are being exposed to so
I was a bit surprised by this so I was
expecting to see lower performance on
the actual than observed but I was
expecting to see such a big lack of
correlation so I decided to dig a little
bit deeper into this and try to
understand why do we see so big lack of
correlation between the observed and an
actual performance and when I need to
debug or when I have to debug a machine
learning algorithm one of the tools I
like to use the most is the
bias-variance tradeoff and I hope in
this room we have people very much
familiar with the idea of bias and
variance trade-off because this is going
to be one of the things that we're gonna
talk quite a little bit if you don't
don't worry the conclusions are super
simple so the idea is that what I did is
I computed the variance of the different
algorithms with respect to the
predictions that means how much does my
algorithm change the prediction with
respect to an input vector when I change
the training set so I changed different
I use different training sets and I
predict the same example if the
prediction changes as I change the
training set that's high violence in
that spot
if the prediction gets it's a stable
then that means my model is stable and
that's good so I did this measurement
like this again you take the production
set I apply the bias exactly the same
bias
I take the label set and I guess they
made the variance in the label set I can
actually also estimate the balance in
the unlabeled set because in order to
estimate this variance I don't need the
labels and that's the whole point of
section bias we miss some labels but
that does not prevent us from measuring
the variance of our algorithm in the
whole data set or in a subset realice of
where we have divided the labels or not
so again I compute the variance in the
label set and the unlabeled set for all
the organisms and I gave me two points
so I put them in a chart but this time
is a stack at bar chart and you can see
all the orders in like SVM for two
decision machines and so on and then we
can see each bar represents a hundred
percent of the variance that we see in
the in the production set and the blue
line represents how much of that
variance comes from the samples what we
don't have labels and the orange bar
represent how much what proportion of
the variance comes from delay from the
examples where we do have labels and
what we can see consistently is that the
algorithms always produce more variance
what we don't have labels so they are
what this is telling us is actually
quite simple we are fitting we are
fitting our ground truth so we can
generalize very well as long as we are
in the feature space in the region of
the feature space where we do have
labels but as soon as we move our
algorithm to a region of the feature
space where we usually don't have labels
the variance starts to to be to kick in
and really affect both performance and
the correlation of the observer and the
actual performance but this is actually
good news because this is telling us
that selection bias is actually about
high variance and we know how to deal
with variance we do it all the time it's
one of the things we do the most when we
do machine learning and what is the
simplest way to deal with high variance
exactly more data and this is quite
remarkable actually more data even if
it's biased should according to this
theory I'm developing here which is very
well backed up by other researches much
better than me so even if I get more
data with the same bias I can improve
the blindness idea I can I can do better
so slit the check let's check it out so
I took one of the algorithms I took a
logistic regression and I looked at what
happens when I increase the amount of
theta so we start low ten thousand so
there are two hundred and fifty features
by the way so two hundred fifty
parameters I'm estimating so if you have
here on the x-axis you have the number
of rows so we start from two thousand we
go their way to two million and only
y-axis we can see the AUC and there are
two curves one is the actual which is
the blue one that we never see in real
life and then we have the orange one
which is the orange the act observe you
see which is the one that we usually
work with in real life and there are
several things to note in this in this
chart first of all at the beginning both
algorithms benefit from from more data
because evidently for 250 parameters you
need about you know 400,000 observations
to fit well with the lucic the duration
allow me to just ignore this dip here
and click create it to noise randomness
and bad luck but essentially at the
beginning both algorithms I mean both of
you know both metrics observe and
actually you see are you benefit from
more data but then we can see that
suddenly the observer you see stabilizes
really fast we are here about 400,000
rows and there's not really any point on
adding more data because we don't see an
increase on on a you see right so you
shouldn't have any more data but
actually we can see that the actual AUC
keeps on improving as we add more data
and in the limit as in totally the
actual you see will converge to the
observe you see and this exactly what we
want that what we measure and will
is represents representative of what
actually happens for completeness I also
computed the variance of the whole
algorithm in the same sense as before
which is this yellow line you can see
steadily goes down in the whole
population sample the violence goes down
of course because I added more data but
the takeaway is that by adding more data
we can alleviate the effects of
selection bias and in the asymptotic
limit we can actually completely kill
the effects of selection bias of course
this is true and there are some
restrictions I really don't have time to
go in-depth into that but let me say
really quickly that this is because the
selection bias I'm introducing depends
only on the input vector on the features
and it doesn't depend on the target
variable all right so yeah I think
that's all for this part
then we just do a brief summary first of
all I have bad news selection bias makes
us blind about the performance of our
models
so if you see improvements you don't you
shouldn't trust them in the context of
selection bias and the reason is that it
poses high variance in the region of the
future space where we miss labels where
we are lacking the labels but likely I
have good news so just adding data from
the same distribution that you sample
your normal data with the bias elevates
the effect of selection bias and
actually we can come up with our
criteria right because if you look at
this chart again if you say how much the
data do I need you would say something
like 400,000 but then you will miss
quite a bit of a you see that you can
get in the actual collection system so
how do you know when to stop well you
can actually go and measure the variance
of your algorithm and if the violence
stops decreasing or it doesn't decrease
anymore significantly then there's not
much together of more data you can stop
adding data right there good so next
subsection of this talk is to bring in a
little bit of formalism this what I call
the propensity spectrum
and in this dynamic you can see it's
kind of a schema or diagram of the data
that we have now usually you probably
recognize X and y-axis our feature
vectors our input Y is our target
variable is our label and in the
literature we find that researchers
interest is variable called s and this
it represents a sample from the actual
population like I care about so in our
example this is a sample from the search
stage so I do observe labels only for
the subset so the search is introduced
variable s which is one when I do have a
label for a particular example and it's
zero otherwise
so that they call is s because it means
is whether the the row or the example is
selected as part of our training set and
now depending on the relationships of
these three variables X Y and s we find
different scenarios and one that is very
interesting which a side which is the
one here where X of course is correlated
or X allows us to predict Y because
that's what we want right that's what
we're building so we're going to always
find X that tries to place Y but if X
also breaks s very well then we fall
into the scenario that I just described
so the reason why we were seeing this
blindness this lack of correlation and
this drop in accuracy is because X is
very good at predicting whether the user
gave us the label or not whether you
seemed made a review or not on the other
extreme of the spectrum s is completely
independent of both x and y and when
that's the case we can just ignore the
problem because actually there's no
problem
if s the selection criteria is
independent of both x and y it's just a
random sample from the population and
yes we get less data so out of all the
people that do searches if we get random
sub sample that gives us levers we get
less data than we want maybe but it's
still a random sample so we can just go
ahead do the machine learning we want
and everything will be fine there will
be correlation and between the observer
and the actual accuracy so we are in the
no selection bias case now the question
is
what happens in the middle right this is
not binary it's not like battles depend
you know determind one body with doesn't
deter mind or not the other virus have a
strength of dependency so that
introduces sort of a spectrum where X
may correlate to us with more or less
strength so one question that is
interesting to ask first of all is how
do you measure how strong is the
dependency between X and s because X is
a vector is not this color if it were as
colored will use Pitzer correlations or
something like that and that's it but
when X is a vector and s is a scholars
binary value well what we can do is a
very nice thing which is using a term in
the literature called propensity which
is a very very interesting quantity I
recommend everybody to study but it's a
very noble quantity in the context of
selection bias and it's very easy to
understand it simple mean is how likely
is that if I give you this X vector you
will see a label for it so
mathematically means Y is the
probability of observing s equals 1 that
means what is a political serving a
label for this X given or condition in
the particular feature vector that we
have in our hands and this model or this
this quantity is variable it gives us
already a recipe to understand how
strong is the dependency between X and s
we can just measure the strength of
dependency by building a propensity
model so we just fit X 2 s so what try
to predict s the probity of selection
given X and if we are good at predicting
that that means this strong correlation
if we are not good at predicting that
that means we are not there's no strong
correlation so that gives us how we're
in the spectrum are we and to measure
how good this model you can use normal
techniques which is fatal generation s
to X and we can just look at a UC or
whatever metric you want precision
recall even some correlation but it
doesn't matter whatever is the quality
of your classifier that gives you the
strength of the correlation or
dependency within s and X so now we know
how to measure dependency or strength of
dependency between s and X we can look
at what happens with the selection bias
what happens to the blindness
when we've already the strength of the
dependency between s and X so this is
the first chart our show I show where we
can see no correlation at all between
observing the actual performance and we
can see that we can predict perfectly
the selection process because the
variables I'm using to do the selection
press are all included in my featured
vector X so that's why when I build a
model to predict s as a function of X we
can see AUC is 0 9 9 9 it's very easy to
predict this because all the values are
there and we get no correlation now if I
remove one of the variables from a
feature vector we can see that the AUC
goes down to zero 65 so that means we no
longer can predict that well it's
slightly better than random remember AUC
is 0 5 for a random assignment so we can
predict with HCC 265 but now we recover
a bit of correlation with the observed
and the actual performance which means
now if we see an improvement then it's
quite likely that is an actual
improvement and that happened because I
removed one of the variables that I use
to introduce the bias I know this I can
remove another one and now we have a UC
equals 0 76 so it's not that bad but
it's also not good so the strength of
the correlation between s and X is kind
of strong but not that much and we can
see that we have a correlation now
within observe and actual performance
non-serious is significant but it's not
that high it's not that strong so this
is yes so first of all I hope this shows
that the effects of selection bias
depend a lot on how much your X can
predict the selection process and that
we can measure so if you're in situation
where you can predict very well whether
you're going to get the label or not
then that means you are very much
exposed to selection bias if you are in
situation where you cannot predict well
whether someone will give you a label or
not then you are not that exposed to
selection bias and the interesting thing
is that the feature vector we control it
we decide what is X because we want to
find X to predict Y so we can actually
the feature selection criteria which
says the following to predict why let's
use features that do not predict s and
if we do this if we as much as we can
then we can sort of bypass the effects
of selection bias we can get less blind
the observer accuracy or performance
will be more correlated to observe to
the actual performance and also we may
see gains in actual performance for it
so how do you do this
well again you build your propensity
model the propensity model remember is
the model that fits X with s so you
predict how likely that you see a label
given your future vector so you have all
your candy there features there and then
you rank them my future importance and
you take the top ten for example that
are very good at predicting the
selection process and you don't use them
to build your actual model you don't use
those features to predict your y so I
did that and here are the results again
in the x-axis you can see the same
number of examples and the blue line is
the observe performance the orange line
is the old the one I'll show before the
actual performance and the green line I
remove only one one of the features here
which is anticipation and the green line
is the performance I get when I don't
use this feature that is very good at
predicting the selection but it's
actually not so good at prediction why
so when we find this type of features
that are very good at predicting s but
not so good at predicting why we should
kill them the hard part is when we find
features are both good at Britain s and
Y that's yeah I can discuss over beers
later but in this case by removing this
feature which by the way is not part of
the features are used for increase in
the selection bias this is phone blindly
it just say okay let's sort by
importance remove one see what happens
you can already see that the whole curve
goes goes up becomes the green line
so the actual performance is
now the interesting thing goes is that
the absurd performin is about the same
it's actually a little bit lower because
when I remove the feature I actually
lost a little bit of AC yeah
nothing wrapping up summary good news
again we can quantify how much this
addiction bias affects our learning
algorithm so if we are in the selection
best
context we shouldn't panic first of all
evaluate how much of a problem it is and
the one way of doing that is to build a
propensity model which is quite easy to
build and evaluate its performance it
performance high we are blind if
performance is performance is low we're
probably okay the second good news is we
can always transform bad scenarios in
better scenarios if X is very good at
predicting s then make it bad how remove
features that's it we can use propensity
base features selection that 12v IDs of
course the bad news or that transform me
about scenario it's a good scenario can
actually cost performance because if you
remove features from their model you may
end up hurting it this is a kind of very
interesting trade-off that we're making
here kind of resembles the Heisenberg
principle if there's a physicist in the
room because if you want the best model
then you won't see it because you are
using so many features you're probably
picked in variable s so the correlation
with observe an actual performance is
low now if you want to see and to have a
high likelihood of an actual improvement
when you see an improvement then you
have to pay for that with with quality
of your action model it's kind of a
twisted trade-off that we need to learn
to make the good news maybe to wrap up
is we can all sometimes it's possible to
find features that you can remove to
increase both the visibility and the
quality of the model which is this
example show here right yeah just one
start to finish more good news by
singing about selection bias I didn't do
much more than that we can come up with
simple ideas to mitigate its effects
like add more data or those selection
feature selection use
simple criteria the bad news is we need
to think about selection bias we can't
just throw data into machines just like
that and SPECT to see any meaning for
the sauce we need to think and I see a
strong trend in the practitioners
community to just automate everything
just throw their - black box and you
will get money out of it and I really
don't believe in that and I think this
is a very concrete and very clear
example of where we're going that's all
I have and I'm really happy to take very
easy questions or difficult questions I
thank you for the talk so the solution
to the selection bias is just adding
more data as you put it nice to think
yeah seriously what I mean is is that
your question for you yeah my question
was in the shortage of data is there a
better way yes of course I mean so data
will alleviate the situation and then
there's a very specific case when is
when the selection bias only depends on
the feature vector so if your selection
bias depends on the outcome of your
process for example in surveys happy
people is more likely to give you a
review than if you want to break
happiness then your selection bias
actually depend on the thing you want to
predict in that case nothing I said is
valid nothing I assumed throughout the
presentation and Y&S are completely
independent even when when that's true
data will only alleviate the issue you
won't really solve it when you don't
have more data well I suggest you look
into how to get more data because stuff
sometimes you can generate more data you
can apply synthetic examples you can you
can introduce some noise there are
wasting you can come up with more data
and of course there are ways and one
that is very popular even managed to fit
in the time is the inverse propensity
waiting it's one of the most popular
ways in which use the propensity model
to happen here sorry use the propensity
model to sample wait your rows so very
much like in this idea where you some
your some your wait you don't pay
attention to features are very good at
predicting the selection you don't look
at rows they are very likely to have a
label that's the technique that you can
use that does not depend also feature
selection right I mean this is one of
them so those are the ones I would
recommend to look inverse propensity
weighting is the name so I have two
questions
clue moved to the exam graph the actual
and you know observed this yeah I found
interesting seen you know like the X and
y-axis don't start from the same value
0.7 and the 0.85 to know I'm going to
make some you know Fisher biased here I
mean if you like the y-axis starts from
zero point seven and x axis starts from
0.85 to understand they are not the same
value so what's that you know you really
you know we I could just put this would
be I just can move this here and nothing
will change right it's just a
visualization I didn't use that the
visualization to complete anything right
the correlation is 0 really how you plot
it right yeah I understand visually it's
in series he has no difference but
visually is he has a difference for
example if an to you know the statistic
statistics can lie it's a good thing
yeah yeah also ok so let's move forward
so about our
I want to know if are these carbs linear
dependency between two Vipers are also
not only non linear dependency yeah okay
I should have said that I was expecting
a linear dependency that's true it's
probably nonlinear but I think that the
chart is quite strong you know you see
an improvement of maybe one or two
points in the third digit of the actual
you see which is usually quite okay for
these two ranges zero eight and then
uses only a drop of ten points of AUC so
that's not something you were expecting
you know I can completely remove the
square R and I can make the same
argument anyway I would expect quite
something more like this right okay so I
understand that you want to make the
difference significant so we can observe
it more clearly but for me yeah okay
yeah also you said to eliminate the Y's
we should get more data get motorized
yes always true in the light but it's
cost E and today I consider to apply
some assemble strategy like yeah I
stated the idea of data to whatever you
can do to lose the variance will
probably help the thing is that data is
the more noble wine the most noble one
because his Harley data would hurt in
any way any other technique that you
introduce to reduce the variance will
you have to trade off with bias put the
other bias on selection bias you know so
that's why I chose to illustrate the
idea that reducing violence can help to
alleviate bias with data because it's
the easiest one you probably other
techniques to reduce variance will also
help provided they don't also increase
the bias too much but that is something
to be seen unfortunate we don't have
more time for more questions but I'm
sure Lucas will be around for further
questions so we have a short break
before the next talk but before that
let's thank you guys again
[Applause]